Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. hello welcome to the rest is history and our ongoing world cup epic and today we are discussing one of the great titans of world cup football argentina and dominic we we talked a lot about argentinian history didn't we we did in In the context of Argentina's football pedigree when we did our World Cup episodes. But you have got a kind of slightly left field theme today. Anyway, you explain. So we have done quite a lot of Argentinian history this year. We did four episodes on the Falklands War. And then we did the history of the World Cup, in which obviously
感谢您收听《一切皆历史》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周独家加更节目、无广告收听体验、系列节目的抢先收听权限，以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收听《一切皆历史》之世界杯史诗系列。今天我们要探讨的是世界杯足球赛的一大巨头——阿根廷。多米尼克，我们在之前的世界杯节目中，结合阿根廷的足球底蕴，聊了很多阿根廷历史，对吧？确实聊过。但你今天准备了一个有点意料之外的主题。总之，你来解释一下吧。今年我们其实做了相当多的阿根廷历史内容。我们做了四期关于福克兰群岛战争的节目，然后又做了世界杯历史，在其中显然
Argentina do play an enormous part because they take part in the first final in 1930. And the story of football in Argentina is a fascinating example of kind of nation building and creating an identity. And in a way, there's an element of that in this story as well. Because this story is a story about Patagonia, and a particular aspect of Patagonian history, Tom. Patagonia? Yeah. The only thing I really know about Patagonia is that it is one of the great places for dinosaurs. It is.
阿根廷扮演了极其重要的角色，因为他们参加了1930年的第一届决赛。阿根廷足球的历史是国家建设和身份认同塑造的一个迷人例证。从某种意义上说，这个故事中也有这方面的元素。因为这个故事讲的是巴塔哥尼亚，以及巴塔哥尼亚历史的一个特定方面，汤姆。巴塔哥尼亚？对。我对巴塔哥尼亚唯一真正了解的是，它是恐龙的重要发源地之一。确实是的。
So they have Patagotitan, which is, I think, discovered very close to the area that you're going to be talking about today. I think, well, there's a place that I'm going to be talking about that has a dinosaur museum, and I was going to bring that up to please you, Tom, because I know you like these things. Oh, thank you. Thank you.
所以那里有巴塔哥巨人（Patagotitan），我想，它就是在你今天要讲的那个地区附近被发现的。我觉得，嗯，我要讲的这个地方有一个恐龙博物馆，我本来想提一下来讨好你，汤姆，因为我知道你喜欢这些东西。哦，谢谢你。谢谢。
I don't want people to say that I don't think about you when I make the notes for these episodes, because I really do. I'm very touched. Very touched. So Patagonia, for people who don't know, it's in the far south of Argentina and indeed of Chile. It's an area of about 400,000 square miles. It's vast. I want to call it a wasteland and that seems too harsh. It's a land of steps and mountains and lakes and fjords. It's twice the size of Spain. So it's roughly the size of Spain and France put together, maybe a little bit smaller. So if you think about the population
我可不想让大家觉得我在写这些节目的笔记时没考虑到你，因为我是真的有考虑到。我很感动。非常感动。所以，巴塔哥尼亚，对于不太了解的人来说，它位于阿根廷的最南部，实际上也是智利的最南部。它的面积大约有40万平方公里。非常辽阔。我想把它叫作不毛之地，但这似乎又太苛刻了。这是一片由草原、高山、湖泊和峡湾组成的土地。它的面积是西班牙的两倍。所以它大约相当于西班牙和法国加起来那么大，可能稍微小一点。因此，如果你想想
of Spain and France combined, so you're talking about well over 100 million people, Patagonia has a population of only about a million. So it's very, very underpopulated. And Dominic, would you describe it as a green, misty, mythical landscape? I might actually. I might actually, Tom. A place of bards and... Is that where you're angling from? And harps.
西班牙和法国的人口总和，也就是远远超过1亿人，而巴塔哥尼亚的人口却只有大约100万。所以这里的人口非常非常稀少。多米尼克，你会把它描述为一个绿色、迷雾缭绕、充满神话色彩的风景吗？我可能还真会这么形容。我真的会，汤姆。一个吟游诗人聚集的地方……这就是你的言外之意吗？还有竖琴。
Yeah. Well, you're trying to give that where you're angling and harps yeah well you're trying to you're trying to give away where we're going are we going yeah you're going to give away where we're going teams so but originally when the spanish arrived in the 16th century there were people in patagonia it wasn't completely unpopulated there were indigenous peoples who lived as hunter-gatherers and they they traveled around in little sort of dugout canoes in the fjords and the rivers and things. Later on, some of them rode horses. So these were groups of indigenous peoples called things like the Tehuelches and the Chonos. And they're pretty much all died out now.
是的。嗯，你想表达——你的言外之意和竖琴？好吧，你其实是想、你是在暗示我们要去哪里，对吧？是的，你打算剧透我们要去的地方。不过最初，当西班牙人在16世纪抵达时，巴塔哥尼亚是有人的，它并非完全无人居住。这里生活着土著居民，他们以狩猎采集为生，乘着小独木舟在峡湾、河流等地四处游荡。后来，他们中的一些人骑上了马。这些土著居民被统称为特维尔切人（Tehuelches）和乔诺斯人（Chonos）等。现在他们基本上都已经灭绝了。
And when you say died out, do you mean wiped out? Sometimes by violence, more often by disease, or simply, frankly, assimilation. So their distinctiveness has faded. Their distinctiveness has been eroded. They haven't completely disappeared, but largely disappeared. There was another group called the Mapuches. They moved south in the 16th century from more northern areas of Chile and Argentina, pushed south by the Spanish. And they're actually the largest indigenous group that are there today. So Europeans arrive in Patagonia in the 16th century, most famously
你说的“灭绝”是指被消灭吗？有时是因为暴力，更常见的是因为疾病，或者说得坦白一点，是同化。所以他们的独特性已经褪色了。他们的独特性被侵蚀了。他们并没有完全消失，但基本上已经消失了。还有另一个群体叫马普切人（Mapuches）。他们在16世纪从智利和阿根廷更北部的地区向南迁移，被西班牙人一路向南驱赶。他们实际上是今天当地最大的土著群体。欧洲人在16世纪抵达巴塔哥尼亚，其中最著名的是
Magellan, Ferdinand Magellan, who sails around the world. He lands in August 1520, and it's there that Patagonia gets its name. So one of his, this chronicler who's kind of traveling with him, who's called Francisco Vázquez, he calls them after a character called Patagon, who is a giant in a kind of one of those very early novels that you get in Spain. Sort of a... Tirol LeBlanc, that kind of thing.
麦哲伦，也就是环游世界的斐迪南·麦哲伦。他在1520年8月登陆，巴塔哥尼亚的名字就是从那里来的。他的其中一位随行记录员名叫弗朗西斯科·巴斯克斯（Francisco Vázquez），他用一个名叫“巴塔贡”（Patagon）的角色来为他们命名，这是一个巨人的名字，出自西班牙早期那种很经典的骑士小说。有点像……《蒂朗·白朗》（Tirant lo Blanc）那种类型的作品。
Exactly. So it's one of those chivalric novels. And Dominic, it's wonderful. So I hadn't realised that it was named after a giant, but that again is perfect, bearing in mind the gigantic size of the dinosaurs that were on this landscape. Back on the dinosaurs again.
没错。所以这就是那些骑士小说之一。多米尼克，这太奇妙了。我以前没意识到它是以一个巨人的名字命名的，但考虑到这片土地上曾生活过的恐龙那庞大的体型，这又一次完美契合了。又回到恐龙的话题了。
Yes, but despite the dinosaurs, Tom, Europeans do not move into Patagonia in large numbers. By the way, if anyone wants to read about Patagonia per se, you must have read this, In Patagonia by Bruce Chatwin. Yes. Have you, Tom. Europeans do not move into Patagonia in large numbers. By the way, if anyone wants to read about Patagonia per se, you must have read this In Patagonia by Bruce Chatwin. Yes. Have you, Tom? Brilliant, brilliant, kind of haunting, beautiful book. One of the great examples of travel literature. I absolutely recommend it. Anyway, Chile and Argentina become independent in the 19th century, and they're kind of competing a little bit for Patagonia. The border is not set. Nobody really wants to go and live there, but they want it anyway. So they're sort of bickering about where the border will be.
是的，但尽管有恐龙存在，汤姆，欧洲人并没有大量移居巴塔哥尼亚。顺便说一句，如果有人想了解巴塔哥尼亚本身，你一定读过这本书——布鲁斯·查特文（Bruce Chatwin）的《巴塔哥尼亚》（In Patagonia）。是的。你读过吗，汤姆？欧洲人并没有大量移居巴塔哥尼亚。顺便说一句，如果有人想了解巴塔哥尼亚本身，你一定读过这本书——布鲁斯·查特文的《巴塔哥尼亚》。是的。你读过吗，汤姆？这是一部极其精彩、迷人且优美的书。它是旅行文学的伟大典范之一。我强烈推荐。不管怎样，智利和阿根廷在19世纪独立，它们在一定程度上对巴塔哥尼亚展开了竞争。边界尚未划定。虽然没有人真的想去那里生活，但它们又都想要这片土地。所以它们在边界究竟应该划在哪里这个问题上争吵不休。
Will it be along the top of the Andes? Or will it be the drainage basins of the rivers? This is very geography. So I don't actually really know what that means. But anyway, this is a crucial question and very important for Chileans and Argentinians. The issue is, how can they persuade anyone to go and live there? Because obviously, if you emigrate to Argentina from Spain or from Italy, where most people come from, you don't really want to go and live in Patagonia in the sort of steppes and lakes and fantastic mountains. You know, Gore-Tex hasn't yet been invented. Right.
边界会沿着安第斯山脉的山脊吗？还是河流的流域？这非常具有地理学特点。所以其实我不太清楚这到底意味着什么。但无论如何，这是一个至关重要的问题，对智利人和阿根廷人来说非常重要。问题在于，他们怎么才能说服任何人去那里生活呢？因为很显然，如果你从西班牙或意大利移民到阿根廷（大多数人都来自这两个地方），你其实并不想去巴塔哥尼亚那些草原、湖泊和奇妙的山脉中生活。要知道，戈尔特斯（Gore-Tex）面料当时还没被发明呢。对吧。
So you want to go and live in Buenos Aires and drink Malbec and eat steaks and, you know gore-tex hasn't yet been invented right so you want to go and live in buenos aires and drink mulbeck and eat steaks and you know dance and invent the tango yeah right talk to the ancestors of borges patagonia is not for you however this is where a man enters the story tom called michael jones and would he could he conceivably be Welsh? He could be Welsh. I swore when I prepared this that I would not, I would not attempt Welsh accents because for an Englishman to do that, even though I do have Welsh blood, Tom, for an Englishman to do that would be a terrible, terrible thing. But I may sometimes slip.
所以你会想去布宜诺斯艾利斯生活，喝马尔贝克红酒，吃牛排，而且戈尔特斯面料还没被发明呢，对吧？所以你想去布宜诺斯艾利斯生活，喝马尔贝克红酒，吃牛排，跳舞，发明探戈，没错。对博尔赫斯的祖先们来说，巴塔哥尼亚可不适合你。然而，正是在这里，一个名叫迈克尔·琼斯（Michael Jones）的人走进了这个故事，汤姆。他会不会、有没有可能是个威尔士人？他确实可能是个威尔士人。我在准备这期节目时发过誓，我绝对不会、绝对不会去尝试模仿威尔士口音，因为对于一个英国人来说——尽管我身上确实有威尔士血统，汤姆——一个英国人去模仿那种口音，会是一件非常非常糟糕的事。但我有时可能还是会说漏嘴。
So if you hear a Pakistani gentleman on this podcast, it's Dominic pretending to be Welsh. Because that is the stereotype. When English people attempt a Welsh accent, they end up sounding like they're from Karachi or something. So Michael Jones is born in 1822. He's a Congregationalist minister. And he has gone down in history as the founder of Ulladva, which means the colony. Now, I should warn you, there are a lot of Welsh in this podcast.
所以，如果你在这期播客里听到一个巴基斯坦绅士的声音，那其实是多米尼克在假装自己是威尔士人。因为这就是刻板印象。当英国人试图模仿威尔士口音时，他们最后听起来总像是来自卡拉奇之类的地方。所以迈克尔·琼斯出生于1822年。他是一位公理会牧师。他在历史上被誉为乌拉德瓦（Ulladfa，意为“殖民地”）的创立者。现在我必须提醒你，这期播客里会提到很多威尔士人。
And so, again, for the Welsh listeners, there will be a lot of absolutely atrocious – I mean, Welsh is impossible, absolutely impossible to pronounce as an outsider. And I don't say that in the spirit of not having attempted. I've actually looked up a lot of these things and made a real effort. But it will almost certainly be abject. So I apologize for it in advance. Anyway, he is born in, do you want to know where he's born, Tom? Merthyr Tydfil. No, Llanrithlyn, Llanrithlyn, in Merioneth, which is in Gwynedd, which is in North Wales.
所以，再次对威尔士听众说一声，节目中会有很多绝对糟糕透顶的——我是说，威尔士语简直难到爆，作为一个外人，绝对绝对不可能正确发音。我这么说并不是因为我没有尝试过。实际上我查阅了许多这方面的资料，也付出了真正的努力。但发音几乎肯定会是一塌糊涂。所以我在此先向大家道歉。不管怎样，他出生于——你想知道他出生在哪里吗，汤姆？梅瑟蒂德菲尔（Merthyr Tydfil）。不，是梅里奥尼斯郡（Merioneth）的兰里思林（Llanrithlyn），该郡位于北威尔士的圭内斯（Gwynedd）。
So he's born there in 1822. He's very serious. He's very Welsh. He's very non-conformist. He spent a little time in America, and then he comes back to become the minister at Bwlchnuath in Carmarthenshire. Anyway, it's better here than Bwlchnuath. And he is a political radical. He's a nonconformist. And he is horrified by something, Tom, which he has every right to be horrified by. In the 1840s in Britain, there was a big inquiry into education in Wales, which many of our Welsh listeners will immediately be grinding their, gnashing their teeth and, you know, rending their garments. And Dominic, it's possible that we will already have discussed this.
所以他于1822年出生在那里。他非常严肃。他是个地道的威尔士人。他是个坚定的非国教徒。他在美国待过一小段时间，然后回来担任卡马森郡（Carmarthenshire）布尔赫努斯（Bwlchnuath）的牧师。不管怎样，这里可比布尔赫努斯好多了。他是一个政治激进分子。他是个非国教徒。而且他被某件事深深地震惊了，汤姆，他完全有理由为此感到震惊。在19世纪40年代的英国，曾对威尔士的教育进行过一次大调查，这会让我们的许多威尔士听众立刻恨得咬牙切齿，痛心疾首。多米尼克，我们可能已经讨论过这个话题了。
Oh my word. This is what happens when you do things out of order, Tom. Yeah. So we're recording this before we do our episode on Wales. Yeah. Which I suspect that this topic will come up. So we may already have mentioned it, but just in case we haven't. Exactly. Sometimes we've had grief on the, but just in case we haven't. Exactly. Sometimes we've had grief on the rest of history for not doing enough Welsh history.
我的天哪。这就是不按顺序录制节目造成的后果，汤姆。是的。所以我们是在制作关于威尔士的节目之前录制这一期的。是的。我猜这个话题到时候会出现。所以我们可能已经提到过了，但以防万一我们还没提到。没错。有时我们在《一切皆历史》节目中会收到抱怨，说我们没有做足够的威尔士历史内容。
Now we're doing loads. Welsh is everywhere. All right. So there's a big inquiry into education and they say don't teach in Welsh. It's backward. It's rubbish. Teach in English.
现在我们做大量这方面的内容了。威尔士元素无处不在。好吧。所以当时有一项关于教育的大调查，调查人员说：不要用威尔士语教学。这很落后，简直是垃圾。要用英语教学。
The historian Kenneth Morgan, Tom, he calls this the Glencoe and Amritsar of Welsh history. Strong words. Strong words indeed, yes. Because kids in Wales had to, if they spoke Welsh, they were punished. A lot of schools used something called the Welsh knot, where they hung something around your neck and it had the letters WN on. So Welsh knot.
历史学家肯尼斯·摩根（Kenneth Morgan），汤姆，他将此称为威尔士历史上的“格伦科惨案”（Glencoe）和“阿姆利则惨案”（Amritsar）。言辞相当激烈。确实言辞激烈，是的。因为威尔士的孩子如果在学校说威尔士语，就会受到惩罚。许多学校使用一种叫作“威尔士结”（Welsh knot）的东西，他们会把一个带有“WN”字母的东西挂在你的脖子上。这就是威尔士结。
And at the end of the day, basically, if you spoke Welsh, the Welsh knot was put around your neck. And then the next person the Welsh knot was put around your neck, and then the next person to speak Welsh was put around his neck. And at the end of the day, the child who had the Welsh knot around his neck was beaten. There's an element of a fun game about that, but also an element of torture and of repression of a language. But as I have learned from Martin Jones's book, it's more complicated, isn't it, than just... It is a bit. ...kind of English supremacy or whatever.
基本上，到了傍晚，如果你说了威尔士语，威尔士结就会被挂在你的脖子上。然后，下一个说威尔士语的人脖子上就会被套上这个结。到最后，脖子上挂着威尔士结的孩子就会挨打。这其中既带有一点好玩的游戏色彩，但也包含着对一种语言的酷刑和压迫。但正如我从马丁·琼斯（Martin Jones）的书中所了解到的那样，事情比单纯的……要复杂得多，对吧？确实有点复杂。……英国至上主义之类的东西。
It's people in Wales wanting their children, Welsh parents wanting their children to be able to. Tom, we're doing a podcast about Wales now. We shouldn't. This is about Argentina. Okay. Sorry. Sorry.
这是威尔士当地人希望他们的孩子——威尔士父母希望他们的孩子能够……汤姆，我们现在正在做一期关于威尔士的播客。我们不应该这样。这是关于阿根廷的。好吧。抱歉。抱歉。
Yes. Sorry. Anyway, listen, it's anarchic already. And we haven't even gone into some of the Welsh words. Michael Jones, he is outraged by this and he wants to set up a new Wales. And he thinks about doing it in America, but he's been to Ohio and he thinks, rubbish, no good. Because he notices that when Welsh people go to America, they lose their Welshness very quickly. They become assimilated. They're surrounded by
是的。抱歉。不管怎样，听着，节目已经开始不受控制了。而且我们甚至还没涉及到一些威尔士语词汇呢。迈克尔·琼斯对此感到无比愤怒，他想要建立一个新的威尔士。他考虑过去美国建立，但他去过俄亥俄州，觉得简直是垃圾，根本不行。因为他注意到，当威尔士人去到美国时，他们会非常快地失去自己的威尔士特色。他们被同化了。他们周围都是
English people and Germans and whatnot. And the Welshness evaporates. He doesn't like that. And this would not be the first time it had happened, that Welsh people had gone to North America and lost their Welshness. Because, of course, there is the famous tale of Prince Madoc. Are you familiar with? I'm not. So the story is that in the end of the 12th century, the late 12th century, the reign of Henry II, the son of Owen Gwynedd, Prince Madoc, is so upset that he and his brothers are squabbling and fighting
英国人和德国人之类的人，他们的威尔士特色就这样蒸发了。他不喜欢这样。而且这并不是第一次发生这种事了，以前也有威尔士人去到北美却失去了他们的威尔士特色。因为，当然了，流传着一个著名的传说——马多克王子（Prince Madoc）。你熟悉这个传说吗？我不熟悉。这个故事是说，在12世纪末，也就是亨利二世统治时期，欧文·圭内斯（Owen Gwynedd）的儿子马多克王子，因为他和兄弟们争吵不休、互相争斗
and killing each other, that he sails across the Atlantic and founds a Welsh colony in North America. What? Post-Vikings, but pre-Columbus? Yes. So 300 years before Columbus. Crikey. I haven't heard this.
甚至自相残杀而感到无比沮丧，于是他扬帆横渡大西洋，在北美建立了一个威尔士殖民地。什么？在维京人之后，但比哥伦布还要早？是的。比哥伦布早了300年。天哪。我没听说过这个。
This definitely happened. Only the evidence for it has been lost because the Welsh very rapidly got assimilated. But Jefferson believed it. Into Native Americans? Yes. There are Welsh Native Americans. So this became something that was very strongly believed in the Elizabethan period, where it was used as a justification for, ironically, English rule in North America. Because they said that, well, you know, Elizabeth is a Tudor, therefore she's kind of Welsh,
这绝对发生过。只不过有关的证据已经失传了，因为威尔士人非常迅速地被同化了。但杰斐逊相信这一点。被同化成了美洲原住民？是的。存在威尔士裔的美洲原住民。所以这在伊丽莎白时期成为了一个深信不疑的传说，具有讽刺意味的是，它当时被用来为英国对北美的统治提供正当理由。因为他们说，好吧，你知道的，伊丽莎白是都铎王朝的人，因此她某种程度上带有威尔士血统，
so therefore she can lay claim to the whole of North America. I think that seems absolutely reasonable. And this was a tradition that passed down, as I say, to Jefferson, who when he sent off Lewis and Clark on their expedition into the wilds of North America, one of the things, well, so a paleontological link, he wanted them to find mastodons because he believed that they were still out there. But also he wanted to find the Welsh-speaking Native Americans that he thought would be out there as well. And what luck?
所以她可以对整个北美声称拥有主权。我觉得这听起来绝对合情合理。正如我所说，这个传说一直流传下来，甚至传到了杰斐逊那里。当他派遣刘易斯和克拉克（Lewis and Clark）前往北美荒野进行探险时，其中的一个目的——顺便说一下，这还有一个古生物学上的联系，他希望他们能找到乳齿象，因为他相信那些巨兽依然在野外游荡。但同时，他也希望找到他认为也会在那里的、会说威尔士语的美洲原住民。结果运气怎么样？
Not much luck. Oh, that's a bit disappointing. Well, because they- They didn't exist. They, that's a bit disappointing. Well, because they... They didn't exist? They'd been assimilated. Right. Well... Illustrating the...
运气不太好。哦，那有点令人失望。好吧，因为他们——他们根本不存在。他们，这有点令人失望。好吧，因为他们……他们根本不存在？他们已经被同化了。好吧……这正好印证了……
Michael Jones's point. Michael Jones's whole point, yeah. Michael Jones. I don't know whether he knew about this. What was he? Prince Madoc. Prince Madoc. I bet he did.
迈克尔·琼斯的观点。迈克尔·琼斯的整个观点，是的。迈克尔·琼斯。我不知道他是否知道这个传说。什么？马多克王子。马多克王子。我敢打赌他肯定知道。
I absolutely bet he did. Because Welsh nationalists were obsessed by Prince Madoc. Right. Okay. Well, that's nice. So he, I promise we will get to urgency. Michael Jones is sitting there back in Wales and he thinks, where should we go? He has various plans.
我绝对敢打赌他知道。因为威尔士的民族主义者对马多克王子痴迷不已。好吧。好的，那挺好的。所以他——我向你们保证我们马上就会讲到阿根廷。迈克尔·琼斯坐在威尔士老家，心想：我们应该去哪儿呢？他有各种各样的计划。
He thinks about going to Australia, thinks about going to New Zealand, thinks about going to Palestine. Tom, that would have thrown a whole new element into the issue. Well, particularly since there is also the tradition of the British Israelites, that the lost tribes of Israel came to Britain and were the Welsh. Wow, I didn't know that. So, oh, wow.
他考虑过去澳大利亚，考虑过去新西兰，甚至考虑过去巴勒斯坦。汤姆，那会给整个问题带来一个全新的维度。特别是考虑到还有一个“英格拉姆以色列主义”（British Israelitism）的传统，即以色列失踪的十个支派来到了英国，并成为了威尔士人。哇，我不知道这个。所以，哦，哇。
The whole matrix would have imploded. It would have done. But his great plan initially is for Vancouver Island. He thinks Vancouver Island should be a bit of a Welsh colony. Then for some reason, I don't know what that reason is, he decides no, Patagonia. And maybe the reason is this, that the Argentines are quite keen on this, because as I said, the Argentines and Chile, the border is not yet established because there's business of drainage basins, Tom. So the Argentines think a load of Welsh people are
整个逻辑体系都要崩塌了。确实会崩塌。但他最初的宏伟计划其实是温哥华岛。他认为温哥华岛应该成为一个小型威尔士殖民地。然后出于某种原因——我不知道具体是什么原因——他改变了主意，选择了巴塔哥尼亚。也许原因在于：阿根廷人对这个计划相当热心，因为正如我所说，阿根廷和智利之间的边界尚未划定，因为还涉及流域的问题，汤姆。所以阿根廷人认为，一大批威尔士人
going to come over here, settle this on our behalf. Brilliant. It's win-win. So they offer Michael Jones 100 square miles along the Chubut River in Patagonia. They pass a law to give it to the Welsh, and I quote, for the purposes of tilling the soil, improving industries, and introducing arts and sciences. The Argentines call this land Bahia Blanca, the White Bay, but the Welsh call it Ulladfa, the colony. And there's an exploratory visit in 1862 by a man called
会来到这里，替我们把这块地盘占下来。这太棒了。这是个双赢的局面。于是他们向迈克尔·琼斯提供了巴塔哥尼亚丘布特河（Chubut River）沿岸100平方英里的土地。他们通过了一项法律，将其赠予威尔士人，“用于耕种土地、发展工业以及引入艺术与科学”（我引述原话）。阿根廷人将这片土地称为“布兰卡湾”（Bahia Blanca，意为“白色海湾”），但威尔士人称之为“乌拉德瓦”（Ulladfa，即殖民地）。1862年，一个名叫
Captain Love Jones Parry. Captain Love? Love, yeah. He's called Love Jones Parry. He's a great fellow, Tom. He was educated at rugby in Oxford. He's a future Liberal MP. Back in Britain? Yeah. Not in Argentina. There was an Argentine MP called Captain Love Jones Parry. That would be brilliant, but there isn't. He's very keen on
洛夫·琼斯-帕里船长（Captain Love Jones Parry）的人进行了一次探险考察。洛夫船长？洛夫，是的。他叫洛夫·琼斯-帕里。他是个了不起的人物，汤姆。他曾在拉格鲁比学校和牛津大学接受教育。他后来成了自由党议员。在英国本土？是的。阿根廷可没有一个名叫“洛夫·琼斯-帕里船长”的阿根廷议员。那倒挺酷的，不过并没有这回事。他非常热衷于
ice-dead fods, and his bardic name is Elfin. Elfin? Elfin, yeah. Anyway, he sails off. He goes to Buenos Aires, talks to the Interior Minister, who's's called mr rawson guillermo rawson that's a good spanish name yes then they go they sail down to patagonia to have a look they land at a place which they call they name it after captain love jones parry's baronial estate in north wales so he's a very you know he's a big grand man yeah he's a grand man and he has an estate called madryn and that there's a town in Argentina called Puerto Madryn, to this day, one of the major Patagonian settlements, actually. Anyway, he comes back, and he's very Eric the Red-like. So he comes back to Wales, and he says, oh my God, this place is absolutely brilliant. Absolutely. It's verdant. It is green. It is perfect for farming. Nothing could possibly
诗会（Eisteddfod，威尔士传统文化节），他的桂冠诗人笔名是“埃尔芬”（Elfin）。埃尔芬？埃尔芬，是的。无论如何，他扬帆起航了。他去了布宜诺斯艾利斯，与内政部长交谈，这位部长名叫吉列尔莫·罗森（Guillermo Rawson），是个很地道的西班牙名字。是的，然后他们启航南下巴塔哥尼亚进行实地考察。他们在一个地方登陆，并以洛夫·琼斯-帕里船长在北威尔士的男爵庄园名字来命名这个地方——他是个非常宏大显赫的人，是的，他是个大人物，他在北威尔士有一个庄园叫马德林（Madryn）。因此，阿根廷至今还有一个城镇叫马德林港（Puerto Madryn），实际上这也是巴塔哥尼亚的主要定居点之一。不管怎样，他回来了，表现得就像埃里克红发（Eric the Red）一样。他回到威尔士后宣称：“天哪，这个地方简直好极了。绝对太棒了。这里草木繁茂。这里一片翠绿。这里简直是农业的绝佳去处。绝对不会出任何问题。”
go wrong. This is the news that Michael Jones wanted to hear. Michael Jones, it may amaze you to know about Nationalist. He's very keen on the colony, but he doesn't want to go himself. So he thinks other people should go. So 153 Welsh settlers embark on the tea clipper mimosa. They pay £12 each. They assemble across Wales. Off they go. There are tailors, there are cobblers, there are carpenters, brickmakers and miners.
这就是迈克尔·琼斯一直渴望听到的好消息。你可能会感到惊讶，作为一个民族主义者，迈克尔·琼斯对这个殖民地热心至极，但他自己却并不想去。所以他认为其他人应该去。于是，153名威尔士定居者登上了茶船“含羞草号”（Mimosa）。他们每人支付了12英镑。他们从威尔士各地汇聚起来，就这样出发了。其中有裁缝、鞋匠、木匠、砖瓦匠和矿工。
Most of them actually, it seems, probably came from South Wales, the coalfields, or indeed from England, from English towns. But were Welsh speakers? Was it a requirement that they be Welsh speakers? There were maybe some of the, quite a few of them Welsh speakers, I imagine. Was that a requirement? No, I don't think it was. But I thought the whole aim of the colony was to set up a Welsh speaking...
实际上，据推测，他们大多数人可能来自南威尔士的煤矿区，或者干脆来自英格兰的城镇。但他们都是威尔士语使用者吗？会说威尔士语是当时的必要条件吗？我想，其中可能有一部分人、相当一部分人是会说威尔士语的。那是一个硬性要求吗？不，我觉得并不是。但我以为建立殖民地的整个目的，就是为了建立一个说威尔士语的……
Well, you know how these things are. I think there's a slight difference in what's happening in Michael Jones's mind and what's happening in reality. I mean, a lot of them are Welsh speakers. Anyway, maybe I would be very interested to hear our Welsh listeners' views on this because they will maybe know more about it than I do.
好吧，你知道这些事情往往是怎样的。我认为迈克尔·琼斯脑海中的想法与现实之间存在着一点差距。我的意思是，他们当中确实有很多人是威尔士语使用者。不管怎样，如果我们的威尔士听众对这件事有什么看法，我一定会非常感兴趣，因为他们可能比我知道得更多。
The trouble with this story, actually, it's like a lot of the – because we've chosen slightly offbeat stories for this World Cup marathon. The trouble is, at the time, the sources aren't actually that good, because, of course, it's not a story that's commanding the world's attention. When is it? 1865. It's the end of the American Civil War. So everybody's eyes are not on the tea clipper mimosas sailing to Patagonia with fewer than 200 people.
事实上，这个故事的麻烦在于，就像许多——因为我们这次为世界杯马拉松挑选的都是一些略显小众的故事——麻烦在于，在当时，相关的历史资料其实并不是很多，因为这毕竟不是一件能吸引全世界目光的大事。那是什么时候？1865年。当时美国内战刚刚结束。所以大家的目光并没有聚焦在载着不到200人驶往巴塔哥尼亚的茶船“含羞草号”上。
Now, the great issue is there aren't many farmers. That's a terrible oversight. Well, they're all poets. No, they're cobblers, brickmakers, miners. That's no good. So there are very few farmers, Tom. Anyway, they sail across the Atlantic and in sight, at last, through the mists,
现在，最大的问题是这里没有多少农民。这是一个可怕的疏忽。好吧，他们全都是诗人。不，他们是鞋匠、砖瓦匠、矿工。这可不行。所以真正的农民非常少，汤姆。无论如何，他们横渡大西洋，终于在茫茫大雾中看到了
they see the green coastline of Patagonia awaiting them. And what happens to those Welsh men and women, Tom? We will discover after the break. See you then. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works.
巴塔哥尼亚那正等待着他们的绿色海岸线。这些威尔士男女们的命运将会如何呢，汤姆？中场休息之后我们再来揭晓。到时候见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《一切皆娱乐》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、精彩评论和八卦爆料。在我们的问答环节中，我们将为您揭开娱乐产业的神秘面纱，带您了解它的运作机制。
We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisent is entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com hello welcome back to the rest is history we are covering argentina almost specifically patagonia and dominic you left us uh on a thrilling cliffhanger what a cliffhanger the welsh colonists have arrived in patagonia without farmers to become farmers. And I suspect that that may prove to be a mistake, does it? Absolute disaster. Yeah, they arrived summer of 1865 for us. The winter of 1865 in Argentina, they arrive.
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、独家加更节目以及抢先购买现场活动门票的福利，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《一切皆历史》，我们今天的主题是阿根廷，更具体地说是巴塔哥尼亚。多米尼克，你刚才给我们留下了一个惊心动魄的悬念。真是个绝妙的悬念。威尔士殖民者抵达了巴塔哥尼亚，但队里却没有农民去从事农业生产。我猜这最后被证明是一个错误，对吗？绝对是一场灾难。是的，他们是在1865年的夏天——对我们来说——抵达阿根廷的，也就是1865年的阿根廷冬季抵达的。
And I imagine I said before, it was a little bit like Eric the Red overselling Greenland. They get off the ship and they say, oh, or they're Welsh, they say, oh, and they are very, they've been on the ship for two months, Tom. So it's the late winter, I suppose. They don't have much food. They've run out of water and they just think, oh, geez, this is not what we were sold.
我想，正如我之前所说，这有点像埃里克红发对格陵兰岛的虚假夸大宣传。他们下了船，然后——或者说他们用威尔士语说——哦，他们已经在船上待了两个月了，汤姆。所以我想这大概是初冬时节。他们没有多少食物。水也喝光了，他们心里直犯嘀咕：“天哪，这根本不是当初卖给我们的样子嘛。”
It's incredibly cold. It's very miserable. The land is utterly unsuitable for farming, which is why nobody lives there in the first place. They actually have to live in caves first. But that's quite druidical, isn't it? Very druidical, I suppose, but that's not really what they're encouraging. I have a sense that Michael Jones back in Wales
这里冷得不可思议。天气凄凉无比。这片土地根本不适合耕种，这也是为什么一开始压根没有人在这里居住的原因。他们实际上不得不先住在山洞里。但这听起来挺有德鲁伊风格的，对吧？非常具有德鲁伊风格，我想是的，但这可不是他们当初所鼓励的。我有一种感觉，远在威尔士老家的迈克尔·琼斯
would very much welcome the cave dwelling, but the cobblers, miners, and so on on are thinking it'll be a bit more like Australia. I think that's how they imagined it would be, and it isn't. Anyway, they arrive there. They build a little fort in the valley of the Chubut River, which is now the town of Rawson, Tom, named after the interior minister who gave them the land. They built a fort. The fort was washed away by a flood. So that was very unfortunate. Some of them died. Some of the children died.
会对这种山洞生活表示热烈欢迎，但那些鞋匠、矿工之类的人原本以为这里会更像澳大利亚。我想他们当时就是这么想象的，但现实并非如此。无论如何，他们就在那里安顿下来了。他们在丘布特河流域建立了一个小堡垒，也就是现在的罗森镇（Rawson），汤姆，就是以那个送给他们土地的内政部长命名的。他们建了一座堡垒。结果堡垒被一场洪水给冲毁了。所以这确实非常不幸。有些人生病死了。有些孩子也夭折了。
Again, very unfortunate. One nice bit, so one of the odd things about this series is it has, unusually for the rest of history, people behaving quite well. They get on quite well with the local indigenous people, the Tehuelche, who show them how to hunt. They show them how to hunt things called guanacos. Do you know what they are? No. They're a kind of llama.
同样，非常不幸。不过有个挺棒的细节——这个系列节目有一个奇怪之处，与《一切皆历史》以往的风格不同，里面的人类表现得都相当不错。他们与当地的土著居民特维尔切人（Tehuelche）相处得很好，土著人教他们如何狩猎。他们教威尔士人如何猎杀一种叫作“原驼”（guanacos）的动物。你知道那是什么吗？不知道。那是一种类似美洲驼的动物。
So it's a bit like the Mayflower. It is a bit like the Mayflower. Yeah. Do they have kind of Thanksgiving where they eat a llama? Yeah. Some barabrith. Llama and leeks. Exactly. No, they don't. Not that I know of. So the Welsh, they make friends with the indigenous people. Over time, they establish Argentina's first irrigation system, Tom. Very impressive. Do they?
所以这有点像当年的“五月花号”事件。确实有点像“五月花号”。是的。他们有没有举行类似感恩节的活动，在上面吃美洲驼？有的。还有一种叫巴拉布里思（barabrith，威尔士传统水果蛋糕）的食物。美洲驼配韭葱。没错。不，他们没有。至少我不知道有这回事。所以，威尔士人与土著居民交上了朋友。随着时间的推移，他们建立了阿根廷的第一个灌溉系统，汤姆。非常了不起。是吗？
And they actually start to grow wheat. So they are making sort of inroads. And so how much of a feat is that? It's a great feat. It's a great feat. Argentina's most fertile wheatlands, I read in an article about Patagonia. Right. So, I mean, I'm not an expert on wheat, Tom, or on farming.
而且他们甚至开始种植小麦。所以他们确实取得了一些突破性的进展。那么，这算是一个多大的壮举呢？这是一个伟大的壮举。这是一个巨大的壮举。我在一篇关于巴塔哥尼亚的文章中读到过，这是阿根廷最肥沃的小麦产区。对。所以，我的意思是，我可不是小麦专家，汤姆，也不是农业专家。
So don't probe too deeply. I suspected that would be the case. Okay, well, let's carry on. So lots of wheat. That's the wheat. That's all good. More people come 10 years later. So there's a depression in Wales.
所以别刨根问底了。我猜也是这样。好吧，那我们继续讲下去。所以有大量的小麦。这就是小麦。这都挺好的。10年后，有更多人搬了过来。所以威尔士当时正经历经济萧条。
Well, that's good, isn't it? I mean mean that's a measure of how well it must be doing so 500 people come about 20 people 20 to 30 people come from new york would you believe to come and join them so they're advertising god that must be quite a contrast well new york to patagonia yeah yeah gilded age new york the world of henry james yeah and uh isabella archer or whatever that's portraits of ladies, isn't it? But anyway, the world of all that. And growing wheat. And they're growing wheat in Patagonia with some Welsh nationalists. Methodists. Yeah. Great. Brilliant.
嗯，这倒挺好的，不是吗？我的意思是，这说明那里的发展状况一定相当不错。所以有500人搬了过来，大约有20人——大概20到30人——你敢信，是从纽约特意赶来加入他们的。所以他们还在做广告。天哪，那对比一定相当强烈。好吧，从纽约到巴塔哥尼亚，是的，镀金时代的纽约，亨利·詹姆斯（Henry James）笔下的世界，
And presumably they're building chapels. They're building chapels. They have their own newspapers. One of the newspapers, Udravod, the discussion, lasted until 1961, would you believe? That's very good. Do they have choirs? They have choirs.
还有伊莎贝尔·阿切尔（Isabel Archer）之类的人物——那是《贵妇画像》（Portrait of a Lady）里的角色，对吧？总之，就是那种世界。然后跑到巴塔哥尼亚去种小麦。而且他们居然跟一群威尔士民族主义者一起在巴塔哥尼亚种小麦。卫理公会教徒。太棒了。绝妙。
Ice deadfods? They have ice deadfods. They have all that stuff. They have a railway. So there's a guy called Lewis Jones. He's the guy behind the newspaper. He is very keen to raise funds for a railway. This is that golden age, Tom, of railway building by the British in South America.
而且可以想见，他们开始建造教堂了。他们在建教堂。他们拥有自己的报纸。其中一份报纸名叫《乌德拉沃德》（Udravod，意为“讨论”），你敢信，一直办到了1961年。这真的很厉害。他们有合唱团吗？他们有合唱团。
And, of course, people who listen to our World Cup podcasts will know that the first people to play football in Uruguay and Argentina were often people who worked on the railways. Well, Lewis Jones wants to build a railway. He's got permission from the Argentine government, but he can't raise much money. He goes to England, very miserable, but to Britain. He gets on the train from London to Bangor, and he's on the train with his daughter, Eluned, and they're talking in Spanish. And a passenger overhears them and says, you know, it's very weird, people talking in Spanish, Welsh accents. What's the story here? He explains, he tells them all about his railway plan. And this man who's called Mr. Bell is an engineer, Tom. Oh, brilliant. And he says, I'll set up a company for you in Liverpool, which he does. And they build a railway.
有诗会（Eisteddfod）吗？他们有诗会。他们有所有这些传统。他们还修建了一条铁路。有一个叫刘易斯·琼斯（Lewis Jones）的人。他就是那份报纸背后的推动者。他非常热衷于为修建铁路筹集资金。汤姆，那是南美洲由英国人主导修建铁路的黄金时代。
Loads more Welsh settlers arrive, all going well, 400 more people. By the late 1880s, the railway is done. And the town of the railhead, they call it Tre Llyw, which means Tre is the Welsh for town, and Llyw is Lewis Jones. So it's named after Lewis Jones with his journey to England. They also go on an expedition to the Andes, very excitingly. They decide, let's try to expand our colony into the Andes. This doesn't go so well at first.
而且，当然了，听过我们世界杯播客的朋友们都会知道，最早在乌拉圭和阿根廷踢足球的人，往往就是那些在铁路部门工作的人。好吧，刘易斯·琼斯想要修建一条铁路。他得到了阿根廷政府的批准，但却筹集不到多少资金。他去了英格兰——心情非常沮丧，不过是去了英国。他坐上了从伦敦开往班戈（Bangor）的火车，女儿埃卢内德（Eluned）也和他在一起，父女俩正在用西班牙语交谈。车上的一位乘客无意中听到了他们的谈话，便说道：“你知道吗，这太奇怪了，有人居然操着西班牙语口音，却带着威尔士口音。这背后有什么故事吗？”刘易斯向他做了个解释，把自己的铁路计划全盘托出。这位名叫贝尔先生（Mr. Bell）的乘客其实是一位工程师，汤姆。哦，太棒了。他说：“我来为你在利物浦成立一家公司。”他真的这么做了。于是他们修建了一条铁路。
Four Welshmen, led by a man called John Daniel Evans, they go into the hills and they're attacked by Tahuelche Indians. Because this is the period in which governments across South America are sort of trying to expand their grasp. They see themselves very much as modernizers and nationalism is a huge part of that modernization project. And that often means pacifying Indians and sort of bringing outlying bits of their territories into the orbit of the kind of the metropole.
更多的威尔士定居者陆续抵达，一切进展顺利，又来了400多人。到了19世纪80年代末，铁路修成了。他们把铁路终点的那个小镇命名为“特雷-劳”（Tre Llyw），其中“特雷”在威尔士语中是“城镇”的意思，而“劳”则是指刘易斯·琼斯（Lewis Jones）。所以这个名字是为了纪念刘易斯·琼斯及其前往英国的旅程。他们还进行了一次极其令人兴奋的安第斯山脉远征。他们决定：让我们试着将殖民地扩展到安第斯山脉去。起初这个计划并不那么顺利。
Because they want to draw lines on maps. Because they want to draw lines on maps, because they think they're terribly modern. They think, I mean, you see this in Brazil. We talked about this with Brazil. We talked about this all the way back in the Weird Wars podcast we did. I mean, I talked about the war in Canudos in the, I think that was in the late 1880s.
四个威尔士人在一个名叫约翰·丹尼尔·埃文斯（John Daniel Evans）的人带领下深入群山，结果遭到了一群特维尔切印第安人的袭击。因为正是在这个时期，南美洲各国的政府都在试图扩大对领土的控制。他们将自己视作现代化的急先锋，而民族主义则是这一现代化进程中极其重要的一部分。这通常意味着安抚印第安人，并将他们领土上偏远的角落纳入到中央政府的势力范围之内。
The Brazilian government fighting this kind of commune of kind of ex-slaves and things. I mean, there's this real sense of sort of trying to iron out discrepancies. Yeah, and nothing more modern than wiping out indigenous peoples in remote corners of the world. Exactly, exactly. The Indians are very concerned about this.
因为他们想要在地图上画线。因为他们想要在地图上画线，因为他们觉得自己时髦得不得了。你看巴西就是这样。我们在讲巴西时就讨论过这个。我们在很久以前做的“怪异战争”（Weird Wars）播客里也讨论过这个。我的意思是，我当时讲过19世纪80年代末爆发的卡努多斯战争（War of Canudos）。
So when the Welsh pitch up, these Welsh guys are attacked by the Indians. Three of them are killed. John Daniel Evans escapes. It's in the middle of nowhere, this place where this happens. But the Welsh know it to this day, Tom, as Dufferin y Matheron, or as you and I would call it, the Valle de las Matires. The Valley of the Martyrs. So if I ever went to Patagonia, I would definitely go to the Valley of the Martyrs. Is there anything to see there?agonia, I would definitely go to the Valley of the Martyrs. Is there anything to see there?
巴西政府打击那种由前奴隶等群体组成的公社。我的意思是，那种试图抹平差异的强烈企图心是显而易见的。是的，没有什么比在世界偏远角落消灭土著居民更具“现代性”的了。完全正确，完全正确。印第安人对此感到非常担忧。
No, nothing at all. You'd just go so you could say? Just how I've been there. And I'd say in both languages. They establish a new town. They call it Cumhufrid because one of the Welshmen, when he came over the top of the hill,
所以当威尔士人闯入时，这几个威尔士人遭到了印第安人的袭击。其中三人被杀。约翰·丹尼尔·埃文斯死里逃生。事发地点位于荒郊野岭的中间。但直到今天，威尔士人依然将这个地方称为“达费林·伊·马瑟隆”（Dufferin y Matheron），或者按你我的叫法，叫作“瓦尔德拉斯马蒂雷斯”（Valle de las Martires）。也就是烈士谷。所以如果我以后去了巴塔哥尼亚，我一定要去烈士谷看看。那里有什么好看的吗？
he looked down into the valley and he said, Weldina Cumhufrid, which means, well, that's a beautiful valley. Beautiful valley. It's a beautiful valley. Lovely, yeah. That's all lovely. And actually, this Welsh expansion is very good for the Argentines because they have,
不，什么都没有。你去那儿纯粹是为了以后能说：我曾经去过那里。而且我还会用两种语言说。他们建立了一个新城镇。他们把它命名为库姆胡弗里德（Cumhufrid），因为其中一个威尔士人当他翻过山头时，
finally in 1902, the issue about where the line in Patagonia is going to be drawn is decided. And they and the Chileans decide that the British will arbitrate for them and where the line is drawn. And the British, surprise, surprise, they send sort of commissioners who talk to the Welsh people and they say, oh, we'll draw, Argentina can have what it wants. So the British draw a line on the map. So the Argentines don't mention that when they're accusing us of piracy. No, they don't, do they? When they're dressing up. Who are they dressing up as pirates mrs thatcher and mrs thatcher and the um thingy billy billy world cup willie from the 1966 world cup yeah you don't
他俯视着下方的山谷说道：“维尔迪娜·库姆胡弗里德”（Weldina Cumhufrid），意思是：哇，那是一个美丽的山谷。美丽的山谷。这是一个美丽的山谷。可爱，是的。这一切都很美好。事实上，这种威尔士人的扩张对阿根廷人来说大有裨益，因为他们
hear much about this line drawing in the andes um so actually in many ways this is a tremendous success and actually by the beginning of the First World War, in the lower Chubut Valley, which is the sort of place where the Welsh have gone to, there are about 12,000 people. In sort of Northern Patagonia generally, there's probably about 25,000, 23,000, 24,000. And what language are they speaking? Welsh, English, or Spanish? Well, this is the issue. They're actually speaking Spanish, Tom, very disappointingly, because of those people, only about a fifth are Welsh. So more people have come to join them. And actually, Michael Jones's original vision of this Welsh sort of this new Wales, where Welshness
终于在1902年，通过仲裁决定了巴塔哥尼亚边界的划定问题。阿根廷人和智利人决定由英国人出面为他们进行仲裁，划定边界。而英国人呢，不出所料，他们派出了几位专员去跟威尔士人交谈，然后他们说：“哦，我们来划线，阿根廷可以得到它想要的一切。”于是英国人在地图上画了一条线。所以阿根廷人在指责我们是海盗时，可从不提这件事。没错，他们才不提呢，对吧？当他们把人打扮成……他们把谁打扮成海盗？撒切尔夫人和撒切尔夫人，还有那个什么……1966年世界杯吉祥物威利狮（World Cup Willie），对吧？你可
would be preserved in Aspect, as it were, has already begun to be lost. Because more people have come, these people from New because more people have come these people from new york people from italy people from spain some people from buenos aires who think oh yeah i'll go farming in patagonia and so the sort of welshness is already being eroded plus you know argentina is a young country it's um you know not even a century old so at the end of that that first hundred years of its life you start to get much more interventionist Argentine governments, which are much more determined to be modern and to stamp their authority on the lands they rule.
听不到多少关于安第斯山脉划线的讨论。所以实际上从许多方面来看，这是一次巨大的成功。事实上，到了第一次世界大战爆发之初，在威尔士人定居的丘布特河下游地区，大约已经生活了1.2万人。在整个巴塔哥尼亚北部地区，人口大概有2.5万、2.3万或2.4万人左右。那他们说的是什么语言呢？威尔士语、英语还是西班牙语？好吧，这正是问题所在。他们实际上说的是西班牙语，汤姆，这相当令人失望，因为在那些人当中，只有大约五分之一是威尔士人。随着更多人加入进来，
And one element of that, obviously, is they expect people to speak Spanish and to be Argentine. So they start to move against the Welsh language. So as early as 1896, the Argentine government is insisting, stop teaching in Welsh in schools. You should be teaching in Spanish. And that only intensifies. But they're not using the... The Welsh knot. The Welsh knot. No, they're not. I don't know what they're doing. I mean, what happens, what you see basically after about, after let's say the beginning of the First World War is, I mean, a couple of things. One, people have now completely
迈克尔·琼斯最初构想的那种“新威尔士”——即威尔士特色能够在某种程度上得以保存的愿景——已经开始逐渐消逝了。因为有更多人涌入，这些来自纽约的人、来自意大利的人、来自西班牙的人、还有一些从布宜诺斯艾利斯跑来的人，他们心里想着：“哦，对啊，我要去巴塔哥尼亚种地。”于是，那种威尔士特色已经在被不断侵蚀了。再加上，你知道的，阿根廷是一个年轻的国家，它甚至还不到一百岁呢。所以在它走完最初百年的生命历程后，你开始看到阿根廷政府变得越来越具有干涉主义色彩，它们更加决心要实现现代化，并在其统治的土地上打上强烈的国家烙印。
stopped coming from Wales. So there were quite small numbers anyway. I mean, actually some historians, some Welsh historians say, if you add it all up, you're only talking about 4,000, 5,000 people who ever actually went from Wales. It was never a big mass phenomenon. So there's that. So people have stopped coming. But also, of course, Argentina itself is a being transformed by massive immigration from Italy. But also that Argentine miracle of the late 19th, early 20th century, where, you know, like Uruguay, which we talked about again in our Uruguay podcast, in our first World Cup podcast, these countries in South America that seem like they're going to be the great,
而其中的一个环节，显而易见，就是他们希望人们说西班牙语，并成为真正的阿根廷人。因此他们开始对威尔士语采取打压措施。早在1896年，阿根廷政府就坚持要求：停止在学校里用威尔士语教学。你们应该用西班牙语教学。这种趋势后来愈演愈烈。但他们并没有使用……“威尔士结”。威尔士结。没有，他们没有用。我不知道他们具体是怎么做的。我的意思是，基本上在第一次世界大战开始后不久，你所看到的情况是——呃，发生了两件事。第一，现在已经完全没有人从威尔士移居过来了。本来人数就相当少。实际上，有些历史学家、一些威尔士历史学家指出，如果你把所有人都加起来，从威尔士迁过去的总共也就四五千人而已。这从来都不是一个大规模的现象。所以情况就是这样：人们不再移去了。但与此同时，当然了，阿根廷本身正在经历大规模意大利移民带来的彻底蜕变；还有19世纪末20世纪初的“阿根廷经济奇迹”——正如我们在乌拉圭播客中再次谈到的那样，在我们第一期世界杯播客中提到的那样，南美洲这些曾经看似要成为伟大国家的……
rich, progressive countries of the 20th century, there's a colossal depression in food prices with the First World War that goes on for decades. And that basically pulls the rug out from the Argentine economic miracle. And as a result of that, you have Argentine politics turning to much more kind of aggressive nationalistic populism. And that makes result of that, you have Argentine politics turning to much more kind of aggressive nationalistic populism. And that makes it much harder, obviously, for kind of complicated multiple identities to survive. Plus, there's also the fact that the new generations maybe don't want to dress up as Druids and have bardic ceremonies and things. They have other things on their mind. So by the the 1930s you have an argentine government that is much more ultra catholic ultra nationalist ultra hispanic so so welsh
20世纪那些富裕、进步的国家，在第一次世界大战后遭遇了食品价格的巨大萧条，这种萧条持续了数十年。这基本上掏空了阿根廷经济奇迹的底子。正因如此，阿根廷政治转向了更具攻击性的民族主义民粹主义。结果，阿根廷政治转向了更具攻击性的民族主义民粹主义。显然，这让那种复杂的多元身份更加难以生存。此外，还有一个事实，那就是新一代可能不想打扮成德鲁伊去举行吟游诗人仪式之类的东西。他们脑子里有别的事。所以在20世纪30年代，你看到一个更加极端天主教、极端民族主义、极端西班牙化的阿根廷政府，所以威尼斯人
methodism is not the thing it's not the flavor of them so basically welshness is pushed out of public life completely so as one historian puts it welsh becomes a language for the home and the chapel and the eisteddfod, but not in public. So they'd actually have been better off staying in Britain if they wanted to. Although, Tom, this is a story with a happy-ish ending. Oh, good. Okay. Because, you know, you've got a few thousand people really we're talking about. We'll come to the figures now at the end of the podcast. And they're still there. And there are still their chapels and their windmills and their tea houses,
卫斯理宗可不是那回事，这不是他们的菜，所以基本上威尔士特色被完全挤出了公共生活。正如一位历史学家所说，威尔士语成了家庭和礼拜堂以及艾斯特富德节的语言，但不再用于公共场合。所以，如果他们当初想留在英国的话，其实待在不列颠会更好。不过，汤姆，这是一个有着相对圆满结局的故事。哦，太好了。好吧。因为，你知道的，我们讨论的其实只有几千人。我们会在播客结尾讲到这些数字。他们依然在那里。那里依然有他们的礼拜堂、风车和茶馆，
often because of the harshness of the weather and stuff, corrugated iron roofs and things like that. But in 1965, they have their centenary. And that's when you see the first little upsurge of interest from Britain. Because basically in Britain, everyone's completely forgotten they ever existed. You get a little upsurge of interest in Britain. They're a curiosity now. They're obviously not a threat to Argentine identity. They're just a curiosity. So you get people visiting. And then a real boost to them, I would say, I'd be interested to know what Welsh
通常由于天气恶劣等原因，会有波纹铁皮屋顶之类。但在1965年，他们迎来了百年庆典。正是在那个时候，你看到了来自英国的最初一小波关注热潮。因为基本上在英国，所有人都完全忘记了他们的存在。你在英国看到了一小波关注热潮。他们现在成了稀罕物。他们显然对阿根廷人的身份构不成威胁。他们只是个稀罕物。所以你有了游客去访。然后对他们来说真正的一个推动力，我想说，我很想知道威尔士
historians, specialists think about this. But it seems obvious to me, looking through the stories, seems obvious to me that a huge the stories, it seems obvious to me that a huge boost for them was the devolution to Wales in the 1990s. Because then that really sort of boosted a sense of Welshness and Welsh politicians and- First ministers going out to celebrate. This is exactly what happened. So 2001, the Welsh art druid visited Patagonia and the welsh devolved government sends teachers to patagonia to teach the welsh language which is really in battle and then you start getting so the bbc sent a report it did a lovely report in 2001 male choirs the chairing of the winning bard
历史学家和专家对此有何看法。但在我看来，通读这些故事后显而易见的是，对他们来说，一个巨大的推动力是20世纪90年代威尔士的权力下放。因为那真正提升了威尔士意识，威尔士政治家和——首席部长们亲自前往庆祝。这正是发生的事情。所以在2001年，威尔士的艺术德鲁伊访问了巴塔哥尼亚，威尔士权力下放政府向巴塔哥尼亚派遣了老师来教授正处于困境中的威尔士语，然后你开始看到——所以BBC做了一篇报道，它在2001年做了一篇精彩的报道，男声合唱团，为获胜的吟游诗人颁发座椅椅
the dance of the flower maidens the hushed conversations in the welsh language the sights and sounds of this ice dead fod are familiar to anyone acquainted with the culture of Wales. But what makes this particular event special is that it's taking place 8,000 miles away. You start to get loads and loads of stories. Great for travel writers, I can see. Exactly. There's another lovely story of 2014.
花仙子的舞蹈，用威尔士语进行的低声交谈，这个艾斯特富德节的视觉和声音对于任何熟悉威尔士文化的人来说都是再熟悉不过了。但让这个特定活动显得特别的是，它发生在8000英里之外。你开始听到大量的故事。对旅行作家来说太棒了，我懂的。没错。2014年还有一个动人的故事。
A professor from Cardiff called Wynne James went to Patagonia and And he wrote an article. He said, it was like visiting a parallel universe. In the Chubut Valley, I found myself singing Welsh hymns, eating a Welsh tea, watching Welsh folk dancing, and witnessing the traditional ceremony of the chairing of the bard. So is there anything that's not Welsh that isn't Eisteddfod's? I mean, are they playing rugby? I think their numbers are too small, small really to support a sort of rugby.
卡迪夫的一位名叫温·詹姆斯的教授去到了巴塔哥尼亚，他写了一篇文章。他说，这就像是在访问一个平行宇宙。在丘布特山谷，我发现自己在唱威尔士圣诗，吃威尔士茶点，看威尔士民间舞蹈，并见证了为吟游诗人颁发座椅椅的传统仪式。所以，难道有什么不是威尔士的却不是艾斯特富德节吗？我的意思是，他们在打橄榄球吗？我觉得他们的基数太小了，实际上很难支撑起橄榄球。
But also that's not uniquely Welsh because, of course, they play rugby in Argentina. Yes. And that's kind of English. You see, a lot of people think of rugby as intrinsically Welsh, don't they, because it's the Welsh national sport. But the rugby in Argentina is a product of the empire and the fact that late 19th century Argentina
但这也是因为橄榄球并非威尔士所独有，当然，阿根廷人也打橄榄球。是的。而且这有点像英国的。你看，很多人认为橄榄球是威尔士特有的，对吧，因为它是威尔士的国民运动。但阿根廷的橄榄球是帝国的产物，19世纪末的阿根廷
was stuffed full of English public school boys. Yeah, like football, actually, or polo, indeed, or the gentlemen's clubs that you still see in Buenos Aires. So in 2015, the colony of Ladva celebrated its 150th anniversary and the first minister of Wales, who was then Carwin Jones, he went. I can't say the word Jones without slightly slipping into that kind of Karachi accent. Well, this is what comes of growing up in Shropshire, isn't it? It is, you see.
到处都是英国公学毕业生。是的，就像足球一样，实际上，还有马球，或者你至今仍能在布宜诺斯艾利斯看到的绅士俱乐部。所以在2015年，特雷莱夫殖民地庆祝了它的150周年诞辰，当时的威尔士首席部长卡温·琼斯也去了。我没法说出琼斯这个词而不在口音上稍微带点卡拉奇风味。好吧，这就是在什罗普郡长大的结果，对吧？确实，你看。
It is because Wales is very close. But of course, there is also- You're cowering behind Office Dyke. There's the residual fear, Tom. It never goes away. They could strike at any moment. That's why it's important to build more castles. That's the, I think most people in Shropshire will agree with that.
就是因为威尔士离得很近。但当然，还有——你躲在奥法堤防后面。那种残留的恐惧感还在，汤姆。它永远不会消失。他们随时可能发动袭击。这就是为什么建造更多城堡很重要的原因。我认为什罗普郡的大多数人都会同意这一点。
Sensible policies for a happier Shropshire. Yes. However, what's really interesting is that in the last couple of years, there were the first stirrings, I think they're still very much a minority taste, of people thinking that it's time to decolonize the narrative of Welsh Patagonia. Right. On the Nation Cymru website, Tom, you'll find an article. It'll amaze you to hear this comes from academia. Dr. Ian Johnson, he says, the Welsh people should confront the responsibility that the colonists
为了一个更快乐的什罗普郡的明智政策。是的。然而，真正有趣的是，在过去几年里，出现了最初的苗头——我认为这在很大程度上仍然属于少数派品味——有人认为，是时候去殖民化威尔士巴塔哥尼亚的叙事了。没错。在“威尔士民族”网站上，汤姆，你会发现一篇文章。你会惊讶地听到这来自学术界。伊恩·约翰逊博士说，威尔士人应该正视这样一种责任：殖民者
arrived in an unfamiliar country and settled lands that were morally not theirs to settle. The Welsh were settler colonists. They benefited from the support of the Argentine state and the inherent power dynamics of the relationship with the indigenous population. So maybe it's time Michael Jones must fall, Tom. Yeah, evidently. I don't think that's a campaign that's going to get very far, quite frankly. And actually, if you want to read about that, I mean, a very elliptical way, a very strange appearance of Patagonia in Welsh culture
到达了一个不熟悉国度，并在道义上不属于他们开拓的土地上定居。威尔士人是定居殖民者。他们受益于阿根廷国家的支持以及与原住民关系中固有的权力动态。所以也许是时候让迈克尔·琼斯倒台了，汤姆。是的，显然如此。坦率地说，我不认为这是一场能走多远的运动。实际上，如果你想了解那段历史——一种非常含蓄的方式，巴塔哥尼亚在威尔士文化中非常奇怪的出现
is a series of books by a man called Malcolm Price. Have you ever read these books, Tom? They're novels. No. You're not a great novel reader. You read so much nonfiction, an intimidating amount of nonfiction, that you don't have time to read novels.
是一个叫马尔科姆·普莱斯的人写的一系列书。你读过这些书吗，汤姆？它们是小说。没有。你可不是个小说迷。你读了大量的非小说类书籍，数量惊人，以至于你根本没时间读小说。
I love a Dickens. Yeah, Dickens is your go-to, but not Malcolm Price. No. Have you read Malcolm Price? I don't know. Maybe. What did he write? He wrote Last Tango in Aberystwyth.
我喜欢狄更斯。是的，狄更斯是你的首选，但不是马尔科姆·普莱斯。没有。你读过马尔科姆·普莱斯吗？我不知道。也许吧。他写了什么？他写了《阿伯里斯特威斯的最后探戈》。
Aberystwyth, mon amour. The Day Aberystwyth Stood Still. No. Is it about Aberystwyth? From Aberystwyth with Love. He wrote a whole series of books. A Tale of Two Aberystwyths. From Aberystwyth with love. He writes a whole series of books. A Tale of Two Aberystwyths? Oliver Aberystwyth?
《阿伯里斯特威斯，我的爱》。《阿伯里斯特威斯静止的那一天》。没有。它是关于阿伯里斯特威斯的吗？《带着爱来自阿伯里斯特威斯》。他写了一整套书。《两个阿伯里斯特威斯的故事》。《奥利弗·阿伯里斯特威斯》？
No, because it's Welsh noir. That's what he does. He writes Welsh noir. I heartily recommend these books. They're very, very funny. Okay. But they're set in a parallel Wales in which the Patagonian settlement
不，因为这是威尔士黑色小说。这就是他的创作风格。他写威尔士黑色小说。我由衷地推荐这些书。它们非常非常有趣。好吧。但它们设定在一个平行的威尔士，在这个威尔士里，巴塔哥尼亚定居点
turned into a much bigger deal than it did in reality. So each of the books is overshadowed, Tom, by the tragedy of the Patagonian War, or the Welsh-Vietnam, as he calls it. Oh, I must read it. That's brilliant. So if you dig through the books, you have to sort of piece together the history. A war broke out in 1960 between the colonists and spanish
比现实中演变成了一件大得多的事情。因此，汤姆，每一本书都笼罩在巴塔哥尼亚战争的悲剧阴影之下，或者如他所称的“威尔士越南战争”。哦，我一定要读读。太棒了。所以如果你细读这些书，你得把这段历史拼凑起来。1960年，殖民者和说西班牙语的
speaking rebels and thousands of young men volunteered from wales to join the welsh foreign legion and they sailed across the atlantic to help their welsh brethren in patagonia and the war has left a terrible scar on the welsh psyche in these stories so that across west wales on the dunes at night you'll see groups of Patagonian veterans. Mourning. Mourning, yeah. I tell you what it reminds me of is, and to show that I do read novels,
叛军之间爆发了一场战争，成千上万的年轻从威尔士自愿加入威尔士外籍军团，他们乘船横渡大西洋，去帮助他们在巴塔哥尼亚的威尔士同胞。在这些故事中，这场战争给威尔士人的心理留下了可怕的伤痕，以至于在夜间的西威尔士沙丘上，你会看到一群巴塔哥尼亚老兵。在哀悼。在哀悼，是的。我跟你说这让我想起了什么，为了证明我确实读过小说，
Michael Chabon's Yiddish Policeman's Union. Yes, yes, yes. That's a good comparison. But all Welsh children in these books are taught about the Battle of Rhyo Carriog, which was a great victory for the Welsh and the great Welsh war hero, Zachariah Lovespoon, who won the Cross of Rio Cariog, which was a great victory for the Welsh and the great Welsh war hero, Zachariah Lovespoon, who won the Cross of Assaf for bombing.
迈克尔·谢蓬的《犹太警察工会》。是的，是的，是的。这是一个很好的比较。但在这些书里，所有的威尔士孩子都要学习里奥卡里奥格战役，那是威尔士人的一场伟大胜利，还有伟大的威尔士战争英雄扎卡里·拉夫斯普恩，他赢得了里奥卡里奥格十字勋章，那是威尔士人的一场伟大胜利，还有伟大的威尔士战争英雄扎卡里·拉夫斯普恩，他因轰炸而赢得了阿萨夫十字勋章。
But actually, Tom, the truth is, so actually the decolonisation narrative comes in, the Welsh behaved disgracefully in the war. It was a war crime. They bombed an orphanage. It was terrible. And Zachariah Lovespoon... Is a villain.
但事实上，汤姆，真相是，去殖民化叙事介入了，威尔士人在战争中表现得极其恶劣。那是一场战争罪。他们轰炸了一所孤儿院。太可怕了。而扎卡里·拉夫斯普恩……是个恶棍。
He wasn't even Welsh. He was an Englishman whose real name was Arthur Frobisher. Oh, no. Oh, you're ruining it for me. Oh, what a twist. I've given it away. No, no, no. But the books are great.
他甚至都不是威尔士人。他是个英国人，真名叫亚瑟·弗罗比舍。哦，不。哦，你把我的兴致全毁了。哦，这剧情反转。我剧透了。不，不，不。但这些书真的很棒。
The books are great. I'm going to order them. So that concludes, Tom, our journey to Argentine history. So people who are listening to this thinking Peron, Evita. Gauchos. Gauchos. Borges, fine wines. No, you've been cruelly disappointed. I don't think cruelly at all.
这些书真的很棒。我要订购它们。所以，汤姆，我们对阿根廷历史的探索到此结束。所以那些听到这里脑子里浮现出庇隆、伊娃的人。高乔人。高乔人。博尔赫斯，美酒。不，你们被无情地泼了冷水。我觉得一点也不无情。
And yet I hope entertained. Yeah. No, I think it's a wonderful surprise, and especially for our Welsh listeners. So if you go now to Patagonia, I mean, people do go. They go to Trelew or wherever, Rawson. They sort of go, and you can go and have tea in a little Welsh tea shop. And so there's about, estimates differ, but they're between one and 5,000 native Welsh speakers still there in Patagonia.
然而我希望你们觉得有趣。是的。不，我认为这是一个极大的惊喜，特别是对我们的威尔士听众而言。所以如果你现在去巴塔哥尼亚，我的意思是人们确实会去。他们去特雷莱夫或罗森之类的地方。他们会去那里，你可以在一个小威尔士茶馆里喝茶。所以大约有——估计数字有所不同，但在巴塔哥尼亚仍然有1000到5000名以威尔士语为母语的人。
They'll be cheering in the valleys of Patagonia. I mean, it's fair to say they won't be cheering for England at all. No, of course not. But they will certainly be cheering for Wales. And so on that note, Tom, I will read you the anthem of Welsh Patagonia because they have. I won't sing it because I'm not exactly going to sing the Welsh National Anthem. It's the same tune as Land of My Fathers, the wonderful Welsh anthem,
他们会在巴塔哥尼亚的山谷里欢呼。我的意思是，可以肯定地说，他们绝对不会为英格兰欢呼。不，当然不会。但他们肯定会为威尔士欢呼。因此，汤姆，借此机会，我将为你朗读威尔士巴塔哥尼亚的国歌，因为他们有。我不唱，因为我可没打算唱威尔士国歌。它的曲调和伟大的威尔士国歌《我的祖先》是一样的，
so stirring. To my mind, actually, the most stirring of all national anthems, Tom. And Lewis Evans, who was the printer who set at the railway and stuff, he wrote it in about 1875. And this is the English translation. Patagonia is dear to me, the new land of the noble Welsh people. True freedom we breathe in our new country, far from the reach of oppression and betrayal. The Welsh have been lying broken in scorn. Well, thanks to the Radfa, from dust we are reborn. Our language of old we lord and esteem, while Camwy flows with shining stream.
如此激昂。在我看来，实际上是所有国歌中最激昂的，汤姆。刘易斯·埃文斯是一位负责排版铁路等印刷品的印刷工，他在1875年左右写下了这首歌。以下是英文翻译。巴塔哥尼亚对我很亲切，这是高贵威尔士人民的新土地。我们在新国家呼吸着真正的自由，远离压迫和背叛的触及。威尔士人曾带着嘲弄破碎地躺下。不过多亏了拉德法，我们从尘埃中重生。我们尊崇并珍视古老的语言，而坎维河正流淌着闪亮的溪流。
Let Welshmen submit to the English no more. Their oppression is ended and silenced their roar. O Radfa, we praise, while the great white Andes, with its peak in the chamber of dawn. It's like listening to Michael Sheen and on that bombshell. Adios. Bye-bye.
让威尔士人不再向英国人屈服。他们的压迫已经结束，咆哮声已经沉寂。哦，拉德法，我们赞美你，当雄伟的白色安第斯山脉，其山峰直插黎明的殿堂。这就像在听迈克尔·辛说话，带着这个重磅炸弹。再见。拜拜。
Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip,
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。如需收听独家节目、提前解锁内容、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、一抹八卦，
and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、独家节目并提前获得现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。